[Music]
have you guys heard of that concept of
when couples stay together for a long
time they tend to
start looking like each other no way
don't say that
i don't know bart and jill still haven't
looked alike in a long time
handsome man don't say that i don't
think i could ever look like steve
i know right i don't think that's
possible do i lose all my hair or does
he gain black hair
it's only hair based
expressions and stuff are mirrored um
really i don't know about facial
features but i've seen like couples that
stay
like they start doing definitely
mannerisms i can see that
yeah yeah yeah marielle has definitely
absorbed a lot of my money she causes so
much now she does i love it
so cause she used to say what the frick
yeah what the [ __ ] and i'm like
david you broke her in she falls down
the stairs and [ __ ] now
yeah she puts her socks inside out dude
she said some [ __ ] she gets her bike
stolen blew my [ __ ] mind yesterday
right
she was uh watching something she goes
dude that [ __ ] is trash i was like
yo that's my thing how dare you say that
she goes i've been saying that
you have never oh my gosh
she doesn't even know where it came from
yeah you have never said that i mean
that's such a
harsh thing to say you know what that
means is that
you thinking and speaking she thought
she was thinking that
mm-hmm that's fine for years exactly
you incepted her dude i got her ass
got him damn back in 1987
1987 that's a good year
there was social psychologist who did he
they conducted a that's a good job a
study
at the university of michigan called
convergence in the physical appearance
of spouses and in his study he had
volunteers rank photos of a
dozen couples well that's a lot it's a
very small size i was like
that's a lot that's like an extremely
small sample size yeah
and deducted that the faces became more
similar
over the course of their marriage as a
result of their shared environment
emotions and activities that's where
this whole idea
came about for 12 people yeah joel
exotic does look more like a tiger now
mm-hmm oh you seen this yeah and carol
baskins
yeah are there picture comparisons
because that's what i need to see
um i don't have pictures what if it was
all brother-sister relationships from
west virginia
we've been looking way like since the
beginning yeah
part of you look just like me god damn
you're attractive
what the hell hold on what's the name of
your mom i'm in love with your daughter
dad can i have my sister's hand in there
no no
mom in love go to your mama auntie's
house right now
well recently in the journal scientific
reports there was this study that was
published called
spouses faces are similar but do not
become more similar with time
they really weren't creative about that
study title that [ __ ] called
um your wife looks like you sir
[Laughter]
sounds like a shitty novel dude yeah so
like they they wanted to explore
this original study from 1987 and see
like people be looking alike
yeah like is there any truth to this and
so
obviously they concluded that there
isn't what they did discover though
is that couples tend to
they they tend to be attracted to mates
with similar that looks similar to
themselves like similar features in
one way or so i heard either that or the
exact opposite of what you look like
oh yeah yeah we're literally the
opposite like i'm
tall he's short he's not short shorter
yeah we are so opposite to the point
where we're having taika we're like i
wonder what the [ __ ] this fool's gonna
look like
and i'm glad he turned out that i'm glad
he turned out like a perfect mix of both
yeah i'm glad it turned out odd but i
was kind of scared
because you're like i'm like i don't
know what's gonna look like
same but yeah so what they found out is
that romantic partners tend to be
similar in a wide range of
characteristics
long-term romantic partners have been
shown to be similar in terms of height
weight
diet diet age no attractiveness
education ability intelligence this is
oh maryland
[ __ ] dude divorce physical well-being
personality
attitudes values literally everything
these are all very different things
what thank god culture oh thank god
not even diet is close for us like i
think she could easily
if i had to pick one thing she'd
probably go vegan and i'd probably go
carnival yeah that's how we use your
values it would be like that you share
the same value
yes yes you share the same type like i
guess uh
social class no well i guess we're both
introverts
attitudes so social classes like your
wow how much money you
broke as [ __ ] broke as [ __ ] yes yeah see
similarities
there we go that's what they concluded
that they literally put
things you have in common yeah you just
stick together uh you tend to be
attracted to they were really trying to
win this study
yeah they're like uh okay so not
physical social class how about this
social okay uh religion um whether you
like the same method maybe
what do you guys both need okay hey they
all [ __ ] with each other or not yes or
no yes you're good to go
what blows my mind is the weight thing i
didn't think that
two would be similar in the same size oh
[ __ ] i'm way
bigger than burial dude have you ever
seen the movie the lobster
yeah yeah it's like that where like you
have to have something in common or
you're not allowed to be together yeah
what's the lobster what's that okay when
you're it's like a colin farrell movie
and ra
rachel you're like that one [ __ ]
freak the octopus guy on the netflix
thing he doesn't love that octopus he
was not in love with the octopus he was
trying to [ __ ] that
octopus he was trying to get that
octopus to [ __ ] him so bad no
yes he was best friend one where he was
my best friend lover was the octopus
probably gonna have some good octopussy
i'm telling you all with all
he refuted that original study by
comparing photos of five hundred and
seventeen couples not just the
random thank you i know seven twelve
that's still not a lot of cops
i'm gonna study at one couple so they
studied them from the at the beginning
of their marriage and photos of them 20
to 69 years later
and they 69 years they found that their
faces do not
converge over time oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
stupid ass
i'd be so weird just like look at your
[ __ ] significant other and just go oh
my god no
no no no no i don't want no girls to
look like me
you know what really trips me out the
most is how isaac does
kind of look like casey a little bit and
they're not biologically related but a
lot of people point out yeah
he looks like he's like you exactly i
don't see it
a lot of people point that out and
sometimes there's certain phones where
there's certain photos where i'm like oh
[ __ ] they do kind of look a little bit
similar
like if me and casey created isaac nah
it looks like you created them by
yourself
yeah you guys know yeah you know you
look like you no one else
sell from yourself you are a worm that
just produced by yourself put a wig
on isaac which i have it is you you know
what's even crazy about the whole like
power manifestation and stuff
my entire pregnancy i prayed god
you wouldn't look like so hard i prayed
god so hard that like
ugly ass father oh
i was just so relieved when isaac was
born i was like
i heard that's a thing that happens
though with the whole single moms thing
is that when the kid looks too much like
the absent daddy
that the kid gets little bit of the ding
ding dong what happened to me
i'm just like cracking up because as
you're praying to god i bet you god's
laughing his ass he's my god
seriously she's like okay i'll give her
this one
i was miserable my pregnancy so i'm like
please let him at least look like me
please
i want a little steve i just want a
little steve running around
what a big ass ass is yeah yeah
he's like trolling people and then you
know how baby's hair no
careful all right just careful because
trolling gets [ __ ] out of hand
sometimes all right
you're gonna you're gonna get mad at a
three-year-old yes okay
troll's really [ __ ] hard you're gonna
somehow change your kid's diaper without
seeing his butt
[Laughter]
you're like let me wipe your butt he's
like no no no no no
he'll poop in his own hand and give it
to you here take it i cleaned it myself
it's funny he has to shower before you
yeah yeah that's so funny i was reading
about how couples like to either pick
someone that
looks exactly like them or the exact
opposite that's true
yeah oh another thing that i thought
that reminded me of
like with this article was billy
eilish's
brother is dating a girl that looks very
similar to his sister oh yeah yeah
yeah where i'm like that's kind of weird
it's very weird do you think he looks
he thinks it looks like his sister yeah
maybe from his eyes they look way
different yeah cause like twins i always
think that they look alike until like
later on you go oh wait they're dude
they're free you're pretty different
because we used to do
hellish shows and people like are you
guys brothers yeah and then we're like
you look nothing like nothing like that
and it's coming from asians too yeah
it could just be like people's eyeballs
racist ass asians they're not [ __ ]
raised
i know the only thing i ever heard about
couples was that you tend to
uh be attracted with like no
you tend to get with someone that
reminds you of like your mom or your
yeah
your personality i could see that
because my mom
is very similar to mario and certain
certain points they're a little crazy
yeah he reminds me of my dad a lot yeah
which and then that's your parents so
you share some of the traits which then
you seek
a partner that is like you because
you're trying to replace what you didn't
have
[Music]
[Laughter]
i just wish miracle cooked like my mom
but other than that
maybe in the future oh she's not a great
cook dude like during the during the
whole pandemic don't you cook
that could be lunch see that's why you
don't need two cooks in the kitchen
that's too many cooks in the kitchen
and it is not even the fact that she
can't cook she just she's too many cooks
too she's this idea that everything has
to be healthy
so when something tastes good i get why
though she's been taunted her whole
[ __ ] life
by what by like not eating healthy
because they've been like talking [ __ ]
to her
i get it maybe but for her like for
example there'll be a recipe that's
outlined very specifically right she
won't follow the recipe and she goes
this doesn't taste good i don't get it
and i'm like because you didn't follow
the [ __ ] recipe
try that that's like my grandma there's
a thing called orthorexia
where their people are obsessed with
everything needing to be extremely
healthy
that's what that's called okay when she
builds ikea furniture did she end up
just doing it her way and then go why
the hell is this desk upside down she's
like drilling holes in it why isn't it
working
it's not very healthy this way
no but she's she's been starting to do
diy stuff too which is kind of cool like
our coffee table's diy that's tight i
actually
like that coffee table a lot of photos
no idea is it made out of cinder blocks
no your [ __ ] was terrible oh my god
industrial design you should have her do
your van life fan
oh that's not her diy that's a little
too crazy okay just very simple stuff at
first
me wanting to do that that's gonna be
research and we gotta cut wood and [ __ ]
like that
i don't know about it just get somebody
that's really dope at it and then like
while they do it you can get one of your
people dude
they [ __ ] slice the [ __ ] up like
nothing nelson's really good yeah
he's your people i like i like mexican
people dude they [ __ ] dope
we are dope you're not wrong
[Music]
you